welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and the Marvels is out
on Disney Plus in this video I'll be
giving you 10 additional Easter eggs we
miss in our original breakdown we'll go
over the tablet diagnostic little Easter
eggs from the comics from the esteemed
Dean valani herself with her interview
with Eric and how Nea dasta used Final
Fantasy as a reference but also Star
Wars or at least I'm hoping she did but
first be sure to check out nerd r. shop
to check out the latest and greatest new
rockstars merch you can grab our shirt
featuring Madam web with the greatest
line from any movie trailer in history
grabbing some merch over at nerd ride.
shop is the best way to support the
channel and all the work we do here in
New rockstars I think you can also grab
the Deadpool Taylor Swift one that one's
iconic it also comes as a crop top and
I'm wearing one right now okay let's get
into it a big reveal people noticed
across the internet is the beautiful
still that is kamala's Intel sheet that
reads species human Heritage inhuman and
classification polymorph there are some
issues with that Intel sheet she is a
human she's not inhuman and she doesn't
have the ability to polymorph polymorph
is like shape-shifting which she could
do in the comics in the MCU she creates
that crystalline constructs that come
out of her her hand but the one that's
got everyone heated she is inhuman but
only in the comics there's a lot of
confusion in the MCU when Bruno revealed
that Camala was a mutant because it
looks like we're pulling away from the
Inhumans and replacing them with the
mutants thus bringing in more X-Men even
the director for Miss Marvel mentioned
there's so many different parallel
worlds and timelines where maybe there's
a world where Kamala con isn't inhuman
acknowledging not in this world are we
going to make Kamala con inhuman but in
the Multiverse of Madness timeline with
Black Bolt sure he can be inhuman cuz it
doesn't really affect us yet
realistically it looks like a slip up
from someone on bfx who read the comic
book Wiki on kamalak con instead of the
MCU one we know she isn't polymorph or
inhuman but every time a director writer
or producer is approached with the
question regarding mutants and human or
the bands they kind of tiptoe around
answering it and that's because the MCU
is always changing and rewriting itself
so is Kamala con inhuman no I don't
believe in our timeline but are the
Inhumans completely out of the picture
no I don't believe that either they
tiptoe around these things because they
might show up and watch them make
another show about them in 20 years in
the last interview with Eric Aman valani
mentioned that she vaguely remembers
that darbin name dropped e on the entity
that created the bands in one version of
the script that was eventually removed
by the final product she mentioned the
planet where they find the quantum bands
on MB 418 was supposed to be the burial
site of eon the cosmic entity that
created the bands in the comics on in
the comics chose who wore the quantum
bands to protect the universe it was
also one of the first beings of the
universe being The Offspring of infinity
eternity and the celestial access you
know they're just one of those mega
super gods and we still don't know
really where those damn band come from
or how ultimately powerful they can be
so that would have just given us a
little insight she also mentioned quazar
when mentioned if there were any other
past users of the band so maybe we can
feed back into that weird Theory world
of William Jackson Harper from quantam
Mania eventually becoming quazar maybe
he still can be who knows at the end of
the movie we see Kate Bishop in her
apartment and I love that in the
background she simply has a Target
poster but it's the same Art and Design
from Hawkeye the two young girls don't
really have a connection kamala's in
high school and Kate Bishop's a grown
ass 23-year-old and Kamala has no real
ties to Wilson fist but we know K Bishop
does in episode two of Miss Marvel we
had the truster Bro moving company
appear during the credits this means
that truster bro Easter egg could have
been a sneaky indication or hint to Kate
Bishop's appearance in the Marvels
additionally this means truster bro
moving company and Wilson Fisk has now
touch the lives of Kamala Daredevil Ekko
K bishop and Hawkeye across the Disney
MCU which fuels our mayor Fisk storyline
and I want to see Daredevil with the
Defenders but what if we just set him up
with the Young Avengers I'll be Molly
whopping everybody if that happens I've
got fidgety hands that can lead to bad
habits plucking out eyelashes snacking
just to keep my fingers busy doodling on
things that should not be doodled on but
with fume I can Channel all the energy
into a good habit instead fume was made
to help replace your bad habits with
good ones that you can enjoy guilt-free
it's an Innovative award-winning device
with no electronics no vapor and no
harmful chemicals plus fume is super
fidgety which is helpful for
de-stressing while you break your old
habit each device has an adjustable
airflow dial and is designed with
movable parts and magnets as much as I
enjoyed the original model I got to say
the new Solano fume might be my new
favorite it's made with a premium Walnut
barrel and an onyx coated mouthpiece
that's a little bit softer fume is
completely natural and uses all natural
ingredients to give you a delicious
burst of flavored air I like sparkling
grapefruit the Citrus is invigorating
and guilt-free start the year off right
with the good habit by going to trif
nume.com neww rockstars and getting the
journey packed today fume is giving our
audience 10% off when they use the code
new rockstars to help make starting the
good habit that much easier she also
mentions how Ant-Man has a daughter and
around this time look out for the little
guy by Scott Lang was released allegedly
around spring 2025 we know Kima listens
to Scott's podcast but if she also reads
the book this could be where she found
out about his daughter though I think
it's because she now works for saber
right like saber's intern maybe they
wouldn't give her confidential
information on secret superheroes just
for fun that information's got to stay
internal when stealing Monica's home or
keeping it warm tomato tomato we see
Carol is wearing one of the quantum
bands it is a simple Easter egg we just
didn't catch before and that's on us
when we get to the big reveal of
everyone's costume Monica's reflects or
comic costume from the 2022 Photon
issues also yeah it's a little different
it's more black I feel like her saber
coat reflects the 22 Photon costume more
than this one though at the beginning
she's wearing an extra white fabric she
immediately tears it off which is a
direct Easter egg to her first 80s
appearance an Amazing Spider-Man Annual
number 16 also please when Carol changes
from her Captain Marvel dress we get the
Barbie movie like the rainning star
effect that they had and I just love
this little effect transition it's so
cute the poster in kamala's room has
nailed the superhero Landing badass it's
a call out to Black Widow's silly pose
which we all make fun of now the cre
soldiers are wearing the same outfits
that they wore in the first episode of
Loki When Miss minutes explains the
multiversal war she shows the animation
when talking about the uprising and
while we're on the conversation of the
cre another thing I noted from this
movie after watching it again is how the
cre basically created Captain Marvel
molded her to destroy and fight then
when she fights back they're like she's
dangerous she's a monster feels
interesting you know like they created
the monster the monster
attacked that's what happens when you
put the monster on the world I don't I
don't know bites back I tried to look
closer but it's it's hard to make out
whether or not this photo is actually a
mom balani as we know she doesn't really
have social media when carol runs down
the stair she runs past this photo of
what could be a young Cala in an outfit
that's styled with the same colors as
her costumes this wouldn't be the first
time we've seen her cosplay as her
future self as well those were my 10
Easter eggs and here are some things I
noticed that are not necessarily Easter
eggs in my opinion but things I couldn't
get out of my head Camala Khan detains
this man prepping him to be eaten by a
flurin behind her the Escape pod reads
number 66 which is probably not a Star
Wars reference but like in a way both
happenings feel the same clearly a less
extreme version order 66 was the mass
wiping of the Jedi this is just cats
eating scientist but Kamala is
absolutely Anakin and that poor
scientist is that little boy that got
yeed and deleted also in the same shots
you get better looks of the saber logo
and doesn't that look like the
Scientology one am I the villain am I
off Carol says for hollow which
immediately reminds me of every time
Thor says for Asgard which then reminds
me of how there's a deleted scene that
alluded to Valkyrie and Carol being a
situationship that was released online
not long ago and also that zawe Ashton
or darb Ben is Loki Tom Hon's wife it's
like seven degrees of Kevin Bacon or
whatever they call it I think that's
what it's called 7 degrees of Kevin
Bacon onto the next one stupid call out
I don't know if it's from the kitchen or
a part of Monica's things but they use
Louisiana hot sauce and Monica's from
Louisiana but also that is a good ass
hot sauce and I'm not just saying that I
actually use it and I'd post a picture
here with me at my bottle at home as
proof but it's black history month and I
feel like that would just do a
disservice you know what I'm saying
additionally darbin almost takes our son
our Sun this is bigger than TM up rising
from the ocean in my opinion so this and
those random flerkin on Earth better
come into play eventually in MCU because
I want to see the consequences if the
eclipse sun or like you just pulled it
away for a second I'm pretty sure we
just drift away right or would our orbit
just like change time I don't know how
this works I just feel like something
would happen and I just want to know and
that's it for my quick little Easter egg
and details you miss video on the
Marvels I had to write this quick and
you know I'm a slow typer go check out
the Marvels on Disney plus and while
you're at it follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Lulu Clemens follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of things you love
check out the break room and the Deep
dive and I'll see you
[Music]
later